Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on guys. This is.
Rob and we are picking up with a vendor's volume seven, uh,
the age of conscience.
And this is the return of moon night and what's probably one of the most Epic
returns ever for a particular character. Here's the thing about moon night,
moon night is one of these characters where mama hasn't really been using him
very often. And in fact,
we really haven't seen a lot from him since the end of Jeff Ramirez run. Now,
the, the importance of linear is run,
which I don't think we ever really finished. I thought we did.
And then people had asked me on Twitter if I was ever going to finish it.
And I was actually streaming on Twitch one day, uh, twist.tv/comments explained,
and people were like, no, man, you never finished it. And I was like, huh, well,
that's kind of wild, but, uh, but nonetheless, uh,
it's we need to finish that at some point,
but the importance of Jeff Ramirez run is a kind of consolidated all the
different personalities of Mark Spector down into a, into a,
him basically kind of coming to an understanding and basically recognizing his
different personalities and not really curing his mental health,
but improving it in a lot of different ways. The,
the important thing about this is not going to do this first part in the way it
was actually written, because I think it was a little confusing here. Instead,
what we're going to do is kind of skip forward a bit and sort of pick up with
the second part of the story to a degree,
but essentially Mark Spector had been experiencing these kind of dark, you know,
dark visions, basically where these kind of nightmarish visions of like,
you know, devils, conquering the world and,
and wiping out humanity and all that kind of stuff.
And his initial thought was that [inaudible] was the one who was causing it.
And so he essentially the moon,
I ended up traveling to the temple of conscience. And then when he got in there,
ended up finding out Kanchi was experiencing these same visions as well of like
devil's conquering and attacking and so on and so forth.
And so seemingly the two guys started working together.
Now what it does is it picks up in loon, right in the temple,
or I guess the location where, uh,
where iron fist Danny ran spends his time when he's not out doing superhero
antics. And,
and one thing to keep in mind is that when it comes to to moon night,
while he does have three different personalities, right, you got Mark Spector,
you got Steve grant and you got Jake Lockley and they all play different roles,
right? Steve branch, the super, super rich one, Mark Spector is the mercenary.
And then Jake Lockley is kind of like his cab driver ear to the ground to find
out what's going on in the street level,
sort of persona his powers or his abilities kind of expand or get stronger when
he's in the presence of a full moon. Now, for the most part,
his powers are not all that grandiose, right? It's not like, you know, when,
when, you know,
kind of bestowed with the abilities of the conscious you gave him that when he's
in the presence of a full moon, he has like telepathy, telekinesis,
stuff like that. It's really more just like improvements to strength, right?
He can just become increasingly stronger.
The difference here is that at the moment,
right now you have what's called a supermoon and this basically amplifies his
powers even further. Right? So it was almost kind of like,
like Moonlight hoking out to an extension. If you want to try to find some,
you know, in Marvel comics, uh, you know, a metaphor kind of example for,
for what's happening here. But the,
the funny thing about this is that he's able to initially,
and eventually overcome the iron fist Danny rant.
And he basically beats this guy into the ground and then essentially steals his
power, right? He uses a what's,
what's essentially an anchor around his neck and steals his power of the iron
fist,
following that he travels to Greenwich village and the sanctum sanctorum of Dr.
Strange, this is a little murkier here, right?
It's not nearly as easy to steal this power as it is with, with a iron fist,
because all you have to do is overpower iron fist. Instead,
what you ended up getting were effectively the priests of,
of Concho who were sent there beforehand to kind of distract Stephen strange,
which allowed moon Knight to sneak in.
And then of course hidden with one of the banks and then steal his power as
well, right. To steal the power of, of Stephen strange. And so in turn,
he V travels to, uh, he'll walk Heights and East LA, and then he encounters, uh,
it doesn't really even have a direct encounter with Robbie Rayez and so much as
he basically uses one of the angst to siphon off and steal the power of Robbie
Reyes, right? So basically he has the power of the ghost rider drives a car,
and then I've kind of, you know, of course takes off with it.
And so following that,
he ends up traveling to Wakanda with the intention of stealing the power of
black Panther. The difference here is that with, with black Panther,
it's not as simple as stealing the power of other individuals, right?
Because those powers are external. You know, essentially with iron fist,
he has the power of the iron fist,
but that is a power source that can be taken away when it comes to, uh,
Steven strange, he basically has the ability to manipulate the powers of others.
So with him, you're basically kind of stealing knowledge for, you know,
you know, in effect, uh, with somebody like Robbie Reyes,
you're taking the spirit of engines away from him,
but it's like taking somebody's clothes or somebody's keys or somebody's car
when it comes to black Panther, his powers in his blood.
And this comes by way of Moonlight presenting a kind of ink,
the same one that he used, or at least, uh, you know,
the same kind that he used on the other characters that we've seen so far.
And it doesn't work because with black Panther the powers in his blood, right,
he consumes the heart shaped earth,
those powers merge with his body's physical form.
And so the only way to steal the power of black Panther it's to literally take
all of his blood, right. It's to kill him and take every ounce of his blood.
And so that's when you kind of have this bit of a stare down here and he says,
you're going to have to take all of me, let's go like,
like take me to Concho and then we'll, we'll figure it out from there. Right.
And so, you know, at this point it's not,
it's really more black Panther trying to understand the bigger picture, right.
Kind of,
and himself to be captured in order to find out what it is that Mark doctor is
doing. Because by this point word of what moon night's done, Reese's ears,
right? Stealing powers of Dr. Strange of, of the rest of the Avengers,
or at least of, uh, Robbie Reyes. And, uh, he's like, okay, something like,
there's some kind of treachery afoot,
there's obviously a bigger game going on here.
We've got to find out what's happening. Now. The next thing is interesting,
but also kind of cooking the books in the sense that with mule near,
because of the fact that millionaire is forged out of Uhuru, uh,
it is essentially that what's moonwalk for lack of a better word.
And moon night being bestowed with the powers of Concho is able to manipulate
moon rock. I E he can control Munir. Now this is kind of Jason,
Aaron making up something on the spot,
because the big question to ask here is that if this was the case,
why have we never seen it before? And if I'm being honest,
I'm not familiar with any instance,
whereby moon Knight has been able to overpower Thor's hammer and in fact,
stop it in mid air to control the material itself. Now,
this is kind of an indirect explanation,
can Magneto control Thor's hammer and using this, it seems that you can,
if you can control the properties that make up the hammer,
you can control the hammer itself. Uh,
and of course the hammer is made of metal, meaning, uh, Magneto controls, metal,
not veto can control the hammer.
This really kind of offers an into how that can be done. Uh, it's not direct,
right? So you can really use it as a credible source. You couldn't say like,
well, I'm, you know, have you got to look at this?
And you look at that and using the transitive property, it kind of works.
It doesn't really work that way. Right? I mean,
when it comes to knowing what a character can do,
you really kind of have to go with like a one-to-one ratio.
But in this particular instance, the fact that it's made a move rock,
and because there's a supermoon and let an enhances the powers of Moonlight,
he in turn is able to control Thor's hammer. He uses it to overpower Thor,
and then he takes it. Of course,
he ends up submitting a whole bunch of different moons from across the cosmos,
you know, from, from various systems out there brings them to earth.
And the just kind of pummels Thor, you know, using these moons.
And that's basically it.
I kind of pulling them together and then basically crushing for,
to a degree Thor, of course isn't dead,
but this is essentially what conscious sense of scent moon Knight on a mission
for what's the overpower, the various Avengers.
The last thing is that black Panther can not be broken.
He can't be broken in the traditional sense, which is to say,
to have him willingly, give his blood over to Concho. And so, because of that,
we don't use it more or less just kind of being held captive.
The Phoenix force is still like, it still exists out there,
but it's currently untethered. And then of course,
there's the star brand entity. Now the star brand,
as we've seen in previous Avengers videos had bonded itself to a little kid,
right. To a little girl. And the Avengers are just basically monitoring this,
this star brand, just to make sure that, you know,
this little girl doesn't go nuts and wipe out, you know, every law,
all living things on the face of the earth,
but they kind of question to be asked here is what's the whole motivation behind
this in the first place, right? As it really just devils. Well,
if it's devils that are supposedly supposed to be taking over everything,
then there's only one person to go to.
If you're concerned about devil's doing bad things.
And that of course is manifesto.
So they end up traveling to the hotel in front of now,
this is where my [inaudible] been since the events of Marvel comics,
damnation storyline, where he was basically locked here by Stephen strange,
this was really just Marvel,
kind of sweeping the Festo under the rug and putting on the back burner.
And it was really mobile kind of saying, he's there, he's in this location,
we'll bring it back at some point in time,
use them for some kind of particular ends.
I wouldn't be surprised if we saw them a Festo in the Marvel cinematic universe.
Uh, it kind of makes sense. Otherwise,
none of this damnation never would have happened.
He would just be in the hellscape somewhere and just kind of locked away.
It was also partially done in order to tell a story whereby Johnny blaze could
take control of how instead of a Festo, right, to kind of, you know,
you serve Muffet those control over this realm, but basically they end up,
you know, we're kind of entering into this place, right? That, uh,
that using the power of Stephen, strange to the ink around moon nights, neck,
that he basically releases the bars. And then in turn,
he uses the power of the worst hammer to punch a hole through my Festo and
effectively kill him right now. The funny thing about this is keep in mind,
my Festo is the representation of pure evil,
but he's a representation of evil in its most pure sense.
Manifesto can never truly die,
but this isn't one of these things where we're talking about like dark side and
DC comics, right? Like true form dark side,
if there really even is such a thing. Uh, the,
the idea of that is it really is just kind of evil incarnate with Mephisto.
He represents how Lords, but he's not a definitive hell Lord,
meaning he's not necessarily Satan from Judeo Christianity.
And he's certainly not the one. All right.
We know that the one below all is what is in essence,
absolute evil in Marvel comics, if, and what we've seen in,
in Al Ewing's incredible whole core, immortal hope run is to be believed.
So my was just kind of a hell Lord, who's there.
But my fistulas and mortality comes in the form of resurrection. Or just to say,
no matter how many times you kill him, he'll always come back, right?
So he's not necessarily by any means gone forever.
But what this does do is it really kind of picks up two weeks after that.
And it basically shows a conscientious use the power at his disposal that was
given to him by moon, right? So if the angst belonging or that,
that contained the power of Stephen strange and those different guys to
basically create what's called feed city, you know,
that was formerly on the Island of Manhattan.
Now here's the issue with something like this Marvel comics used to be, uh,
they,
they used to write their stories in such a way to where the only time you would
see something like this,
this significant on a huge scale is if there was a crossover now that was back
in the seventies and the eighties, a lot of things have changed, right?
Especially during the late nineties, going into the early two thousands,
this kind of act wouldn't normally be reserved for a crossover back in the day,
right? Marble used to be very similar to DC, DC. Wouldn't do this. For example,
while you wouldn't see something like this, you would see it,
but you would see it referenced in other comics.
You don't really see a reference to anybody else's comic, right?
It's not as though we've been reading sorts of acts and it's like,
meanwhile and Manhattan,
the entire Island's been turned into a giant shrine for Khan Shu, the adoption,
God of the moon. Like it's not really something that you saw, right?
So it's one of these things where you kind of have to play it fast and loose.
And I,
and I simply say that because a lot of the guys were probably going to ask why
haven't we seen this in anybody else's books,
because it's just kind of how things are being done, right? Like every,
you know, almost every single individual comic has its own major event going on,
which really is one of the things that people kind of get burned out on. Right.
When everything seems like a big deal.
The reality is that when you write what are effectively villain of the villain
of the week, stories, people get bored, right?
So mobile's really just kind of throwing things at the wall and seeing what
sticks and so far, this is kind of what sticks. And so from there,
you basically switch over to black Panther and the belief of,
to Cholla is that moon Knight is not operating of his own accord, right?
He's not operating of his own mind.
The other part of this is that the servants of,
of a conscience or trying to get black Panther to basically acquiesce, right.
They're trying to break him, they got him chained up. They're basically,
you know, whipping him with, uh, with, uh, with basically, you know,
or at least flogging him, right. With these, you know, these whips that contain,
uh, Jagen,
moonstones just literally trying to break this guy down on the most basic level.
But as we know what the challah, the guy never gives up, right?
Like the guy never, ever backs down the willpower of,
to challah is absolutely insane.
And so when moon night shows up here and it's just, you know, when to Charles,
like, you know, why are you doing this? Like, you know, Concho, like, you know,
we have to find a way to get Concho out of your head.
The response of moon Knight is no.
I've had these visions of devils conquering the world up Mo you know,
conscious had the exact same villains we're working together to save you guys.
And we're going to, we need to take your power in order to do it right.
So it's not really, as though this is kind of an evil thing.
And that's one of the things to understand about this, right?
That con shoe has historically manipulated. Moonlight, tripped him,
used him for his own ends, but this instance, it really is different here,
but it really is different in some way,
they're going about it in all the worst possible ways,
but it really is different in these particular ways,
but it's really more or less Mark Spector saying, look,
I'm not being mind controlled, right? Like I'm doing this of my own accord.
Like I'm doing this because I choose to,
because it's what we need to do in order to save everyone.
The other part of this is that moon Knight, uh, doesn't fully trust Concho.
And it kind of makes sense just because of the,
the shady history they have together.
And this comes in the form of black Panther, kind of, can you really trying to,
to, you know, trying to get them understand none of this is a good idea, right?
None of nothing that you're doing here has beneficial and so on and so forth.
And that's what Mark spectra says, like I'm not blind to what I've done. Right.
I understand the significance of turning on people who have historically been my
teammates, even if we haven't necessarily teamed up all the time.
And even if we fought before, right?
Like I understand the significance of what I'm doing.
And I haven't given Concho all the powers in my possession.
I'm not blindly following this guy.
And he basically reveals that he's in possession of the Phoenix force, right?
Like he's got the Phoenix force at his disposal and he ends up revealing here.
That,
of course he is in possession of still possession of the ghost riders powers.
Right. What's, you're not small.
And that's one of the things to kind of keep in mind.
The ghost writer is one of these guys where it's so easy to throw them under the
kind of Superman under the rock. Right.
And to assume that there's not much that ghost rider has to offer in terms of
abilities, right. Then you just kind of a guy who's there. Uh,
the cool thing about ghost rider is he's exceedingly powerful, right?
Like he's powerful enough to take on all kinds of different guys. And in fact,
ghost face off against Galactus before.
So it's not like it's a really small amount of power, right?
It's only you become a ghost rider and you can lift like three tons.
It's not like that. Right. It's, it's a, it's basically the power of,
of a God is the power of the devil being used, you know, for,
for any number of goals and achievements or whatever it is that you want to do.
You're the part of this is that with the, the binds around black Panther,
kind of been, uh,
kind of being weakened when the various servants come back and come back in with
the intention of, of literally trying to break him down again, by whipping him,
uh,
he literally breaks out of his chains and then starts beating the crap out of
them. Right? So like at that point, they,
they kind of flea and ask Kanchi to save them. Now,
pick up with iron man and pick up with Carol Danvers, right?
They've got the little kid star brand with them.
They're trying to keep this little kid away from Kanchi as best they can.
But for iron man,
he sees this as like a very personal mission that he has to go on. Right.
Because remember when we talked about the, the previous,
sorry that we had of Ironman being stuck in the past with the Avengers 1
million,
when he was eventually presented with a time stone by [inaudible] brought him
back to the modern day that he kind of saw a little bit of these visions.
And so it's,
this is going to be kind of an important thing because that's the role he's
playing.
We'll find out a little bit more about why that matters here in a minute,
but the, the, the, the big thing about this is that again,
with Mephisto because of the fact that he always comes back, ah,
you end up having like these and iterations on the Festo manifesting, right?
One who's like, uh, one was like a pirate, right?
News revolvers with hellfire bullets, that computer souls,
different things like that. Just kind of popping back up here and there.
And it's basically Concho just constantly killing Sophisto. Now,
to be honest with you guys,
I don't really believe conscious powerful enough to kill the Festo.
And the Festo is a universal entity. He's wildly powerful, you know, in,
in his own way,
the way in which they were able to kill him before the longer Mephisto stays
away from his realm among the hell Lords, the weaker he gets.
So it wouldn't make sense like when they visited him in that cell,
they could actually kill him. But when he manifests,
he should be as powerful as he could possibly be. And that's no small thing,
right? This guy's nuts in terms of its power.
Concho was never really being shown to be that powerful before,
but he's also a character that we haven't really seen that much before.
And so in a lot of ways, uh, Jason,
Aaron is kind of flying by the seat of his pants,
with the power of the country possesses and what it is that he can do. Right.
So I guess it's kind of believable in that way,
because we don't really have much to tell us that it shouldn't be done,
but regardless,
what country's been doing is basically killing all these versions of manifesto.
They keep manifesting, but every time one comes back in this band, you know,
a little over a hundred so far every time, you know, Memphis STO comes back,
country fights him and then kills him, right.
It's just kind of been going on consistently at the same time,
you've got captain America,
you've got blade and you've got Shiho who were launching an effort to find like
Danny Rand, uh, you know, the iron fist, trying to find Stephen strange,
those individuals whose powers were taken by Concho and whose conscious forces
had kind of, you know, basically taken into hiding or, or, you know,
kind of you remove them from the landscape. Now,
this matters is because in an effort to entrap the rest of the Avengers,
the forces of conscience kind of let it slip that like these guys were going to
be on this train, right? Steven strain, Danny ran the iron fist, uh,
Robbie Reyes, and they were going to be on this train, captain America,
and his team took debate and then basically rescued these guys, right.
That leads to the forces of conscious showing up.
And then all hell kind of breaking loose among these,
these various forces here at the same time that happens, uh,
mood night actually ends up going directly after Ironman and Carol Danvers.
Right. And it's a little bit of bickering here. It's kind of funny, you know,
watching like 20, soccer's kind of an idiot trying to take care of a kid,
which is he's completely ill-equipped to do,
but he recognizes the significance of this kid and recognizes the significance
of what could happen if the visions of Concho and moon knife or actually
correct. And so there's a point whereby moon night shows up here,
he captures Carol Danvers and then goes to attack,
or at least goes to try to take the baby away from, uh, from,
from Tony stark using the power of the ghost writer.
And then basically says like, like basically makes mention and saying that like,
you know, everything that we fought for is going to die, right?
You have to let me finish what I started or everything's going to die if we let
manifesto win. And the fact that he references Mephisto tells Tony stark,
this ties into his whole experience. Right.
And we'll have that video down in the description in case you guys want to get
caught up. I don't want you guys to feel left out or anything, but, uh, but,
but in that moment,
because of the fact that this kind of goes towards quite literally stopping
Festo, when these kinds of devils more or less,
they seem to be popping up again, we don't really know that's actually the case.
We're largely just kind of assuming alongside moon Knight and Concho that he
initially was going to give the kid over to Moonlight that in turn basically
leads to Carol Danvers, kind of freeing herself, jumping in,
grabbing Tony stark in the baby and flying away. Right. And Tony Stark's like,
do not let me near him again. And like, do not let me near this baby again,
like take this baby and fly away as far as you can. Right.
Because if something like, like, if this happens again,
I will end up giving this kid to, to Moonlight. Right. I don't want to,
but I'm driven to, okay. Like I kind of have this, this drive to,
and so of course, with black Panther,
freeing himself from the various guys who are out there, you know,
freeing himself from the priests of conscience,
he goes to basically confront Concho himself, right.
To confront this guy himself. Now,
the reason why this is kind of important here is because in this moment,
when moon nights had, had basically kind of been left, right. With,
with Carol Danvers, grabbing Ironman and the baby,
and then flying away that in an effort to kind of understand whether or not
Kanchi was telling him the, he ended up going to the moon, right.
For a moment of solitude,
just kind of staying there and just kind of thinking for a minute or two.
And he's met by the unseen now,
for those of you guys who aren't really familiar with the sky,
because it's been a long time since we really covered him, uh,
the unseen is classic Nick fury from back in the day, right? Like old school,
white guy, Nick fury, for that, you guys know who he is, right. It's like,
here's a picture of what he looks like of old school. Nick fury,
this is a picture of what he looks like, you know him when you see him.
But the idea was that during the original sin story,
back in 2014 or whenever it was,
it was written as part of the lead up to Hickman's Avengers, new Avengers,
and eventually secret Wars on then of course we'll have that description as
well. That, that whole playlist, my editors, whoever this is,
we'll post this under the description, the idea behind that was it,
Nick fury had basically killed the watcher in order to cover his own tracks for
something that he had done.
The results of this is that when it came out that Nick furry was the one who had
done it, the other Watchers banded together and then confined him to the moon.
Right. So no one really knows he's there. I mean, some do here and there,
like people who kind of go by there happened to see him, something like that.
But he's basically confined for essentially all existence to stay locked and
chained to the moon and, and able to witness everything that happens on earth,
but being unable to do anything about it right now, even then,
he's still pretty ambiguous. I mean, it makes it clear. Jason air makes it very,
very clear Nick fury, as we knew him as long since dead.
And it's basically just the unseen as he calls himself.
But what he basically tells new night here is you've been praying to Concho all
this time. But if you're going to win this, you can't pray to him.
You're the only one who can really end this.
You cannot pray to Taconcha anymore.
You have to learn to pray with different God. And when you do that,
when you give yourself over fully to that, God, then in turn,
you'll possess the kind of power that you need in order to essentially save the
day. And so what you end up getting here is,
is you kind of jumped back to black Panther, confronting Honshu,
and ultimately being met by, by moon night.
Now moon Knight had come back here with the intention of confronting Concho
himself,
but in the recognition that black Panther was here and realizing that with these
two teaming up that most likely you would have to be forced to flee that this
led to constitute using the power of Dr. Strange to trick the mind of moon
Knight into believing that black Panther was manifesto.
And so literally it's an illusion.
And so moon nights just fighting against the sky as best as he possibly can.
Now, ultimately does this fight drags on pretty far?
And it's kind of interesting to see this, to be honest with you guys. I mean,
one of the funny things that happens is that honcho throws his hammer throws a
hammer of mule near, uh, at, at black Panther and black Panther,
like catches it. And then,
and just like literally shows that like he's worthy of lifting it.
The funny thing is he doesn't use it and that's,
that's kind of see that is how it needs to be needed to be done. Like,
in my mind, showing a person's worthy of really Mueller is one thing.
But like when you show they're worthy and then you in turn,
use that worthy yeah. That person picks up the hammer and then starts fighting.
It kind of cheapens. It. They're like, yeah, I'm worthy of using it,
but I don't need it. Right. Like I can, I can do this on my own.
We're just kind of an important thing, right?
It's a cool little moment there because what you end up getting is that with
this illusion being cast and,
and Moonlight facing off against like Panther black Panther trusts are
reasonably them as best he can.
But black Panther also ends up putting the full of it was martial arts,
literally on display here, right?
The flying leopard clock hick the black mambas spine strike the hippo fists were
just kind of an interesting name for a martial arts move,
but like the fist of Kanchi,
which moon Knight tries to use on black Panther and it doesn't work. Right.
He just,
he just basically overcomes like one of the coolest names here is the rage of
many Willdabeast. That's an amazing name for like a, for, for like an assault.
I think it's cool.
But basically black Panther is able to get the upper hand on Moonlight and then
incapacitated. Now,
the reason why this matters is because moon Knight had long since feel a
realized he was under the spell of an illusion, right.
That he was under the spell of,
of conscience using the power of Steven strange and basically says like, like,
you know,
you're going to have to make me believe you're gonna have to like pummel me.
You know, if, if, you know,
if I'm going to succeed here is a little bit ambiguous,
but we basically ended up realizing that in doing this,
he's basically casting off the influence of Concho and casting off his faith and
belief and conscience.
The reason why this matters it because it in turn allows the Phoenix force to
bind itself, to, uh, to, to Moonlight. Now, again,
the Phoenix is part of the original Avengers, right?
And that's really the power source.
The Kanchi was going after the power of all the original Avengers, right? The,
the Avengers 1 million BC that you had a, you had a basically Mueller,
which was being used by, uh, by Odin that you had. Um,
you had the Phoenix force, you had the first black Panther. You had like the,
the first star brand, or really the second star brand. The first one was, uh,
a Tyrannosaurus Rex. But like you had the second star brand.
That's what the power of the country was going after the power of the original
Avengers to destroy whatever threat this was, that was coming towards earth.
But Moonlight absorbing the totality of the Phoenix force unto himself,
and then taking off into space really kind of changes things because the truth
about this is this feels like it should be a major crossover event,
a lot more significant than what you would see in a story like this.
But at the same time,
it is also the Avengers comics and under normal circumstances,
if we were talking about the Avengers comics 15 years ago,
it wouldn't be this big, right.
It wouldn't be like a massive spacefaring event with like a person being imbued
with a full power of the Phoenix force. And then like going to town on like, uh,
an Egyptian God of the sun.
You wouldn't really see that ever since the Marvel cinematic universe.
And like the first Avengers movie,
there's always kind of been this demand in comics to, to amp things up, right.
To make like the Avengers as big and comics as they are in the movies,
kind of this expectation that coming from those movies and sitting down and
reading an Avengers comic, you're going to see like these insane story arcs.
And that's really where we are now, right?
That's why the Avengers comics are being written this way,
because it's kind of what people expect after having gone and see the movies.
That's one of the drawbacks of the movies, right?
Because you end up seeing a removal of character-driven stories.
And instead it focuses on like big, high octane action events,
which there's not always room to do both. And this one there is,
but there's not always room to do both of that across the board.
And that's kind of the problem that you run into. If you have to choose one,
which one do you choose,
but mood nights showing up here and beating the crap out of Concho after
realizing that he's basically being manipulated, uh, it leads to, of course,
you know, the, the attempt of him to take the star band child away from,
from iron man and our Carol Danvers only to be declined. And then to say, okay,
fine. Then get the kid out of here. Right? Like,
I don't mean any harm to this kid. This kid wants to screw me up. And, uh, the,
the,
the whole point of the star brands power is to be powerful enough to overcome
any foe he faces off against him is the reason why in Hickman's of vendors and
new Avengers,
one star brand was able to destroy one beyond her because it was facing off
against one,
beyond her at the time ended up destroying the entirety of the star brand.
Why do you end up having to kill himself? Or at least he was already dying,
but he ended up destroying his physical body, you know,
in order to actually destroy that one beyond her. But like,
it would be enough power to take out Mark Spector. If that,
if that maybe had full, full control of the star brand's power,
but the fight between these two guys where you end up having, you know,
conscious, you basically knocked back down to the surface.
The responsive Concho is to tell us forces a massive many of yourselves as you
can, right?
Like the full totality of my forces face off against these guys here.
I will deal with Moonlight out in space as best I can.
The problem with that is that as soon as he starts to come to you end up having
the arrival of Robbie Rayez and Robbie Reyes and black Panther ended up stealing
or end up taking the adjuncts of a, of Concho and taking their power.
And you'll take into the power from Concho and then giving it basically two
different Avengers, right? Siemens strange, still knocked out. Rodney Reyes has,
has come to.
And so you end up seeing this power being given to like she Hulk who ends up
becoming the new iron fist blade, who becomes a new source or a Supreme.
And then of course, Robbie Reyes ends up getting his own, uh,
getting his ghost writer hire back. Now it's not going to stay this way,
but it is kind of a cool little shift up, you know,
even if only in the moment to see this kind of thing, go down.
The problem with this is that while you have Mark specter out, out, you know,
kind of hovering above the earth with the power of the Phoenix force,
he starts to realize this power is too much for him to control.
And it's literally sitting as mental illness into disarray because remember the
Phoenix force really seems to kind of go nuts if it starts experiencing emotions
or concepts that it didn't experience before.
There was a whole idea behind the dark Phoenix saga,
the Phoenix force started experiencing jealousy, rage, you know,
different emotions of the Phoenix had never really been,
never really been privy to and experiencing those,
set it on this dark and twisted path where like it corrupted Jean Gray and just
kind of went nuts. And this instance,
the Phoenix force is experiencing multiple personality disorder.
If it stated the same bonded to Mark spectra enough,
it could actually drive the Phoenix force insane. But in this instance,
Mark begins to realize the Phoenix force is making his mental illness worse.
And so in order to, to essentially overcome it,
when Thor re-emerges from all these worlds that have kind of been crushed
together to keep them, keep them held apart, to keep them in stasis,
he summons his hammer back to him realizing that his hammers close and then like
pummels moon night and sends them crashing back down to earth. You know,
he ends up pummeling moon night,
the Phoenix force leaves moon night kind of goes back out,
does whatever it is it is going to do. But in that moment,
he's more or less defeated following that you end up having, you know,
Moonlight kind of crash landing on earth.
Phoenix force takes off Kanchi wakes up and then conscious and turn apprehended
by the Avengers.
But not before saying I did all of this in order to like protect the world from
that threat, right? From these devils that are going to invade.
You're not going to have the power for that.
But the response to the Avengers is done. We'll find that power ourselves,
right. But it's not the job of some moon. God, who's more or less, you know,
kind of gone nuts to take that role unto himself. Right? Like, you know,
even though he was coming from a place of, of altruism, it's not the best thing.
The other question that really comes out of this is what's going to happen with
the Phoenix force. If any of you guys had read Jason Aaron's, uh, the,
basically his, his Thor, you end up finding out at a future point in time,
Wolverine bonds to the Phoenix force.
And that really is kind of what he seems to be pointing out here. Right?
That where you end up having Jean Gray,
who was kind of watching all that go down, that is kind of like, okay,
like something's coming, right.
Jean Gray recognizes the Phoenix force is coming again.
Or the Phoenix force is out there on earth.
And it's looking for a suitable host and where Jean Ray says,
it's not looking for me. Then the response, the question is,
who is it looking for and what we're not necessarily given a definitive answer
here. It looks like it's going to end up bonding itself to Wolverine.
We'll find out whether that's true or not, but that's what it looks like.
It's going to do. What would that being said, guys,
we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to come and explain mission,
you guys have the sub button to become part of the Rob for,
if you guys enjoyed this video,
make sure you drop a light that will catch you all later.
Bruce.
[inaudible].